the first case of monkey pox confirmed
that a CCSD school it is one of 75
tallied by the health district the
principal of Palo Verde High School
alerting families today Sasha Loftus
live in studio she spoke with parents
and an expert tonight and now joins us
Sasha Brian parents we spoke with today
we're a little concerned to see
something like this at their kids school
the risk of transmission is still very
low he's not surprised to see more cases
everyone's just like waiting for the
other shoe to drop news that hits too
close to home just one more thing on the
list to safeguard from That's How
parents at Palo Verde High School
reacted to Friday's announcement that a
person on campus was diagnosed with
monkeypox you kind of hope it's not the
school your kids go to but it is the
principal sent this message to parents
saying they're working with the Southern
Nevada Health District to keep everyone
safe and what we're seeing at in a CCSD
school is the same as we're seeing in
the communities snhd says Clark County
currently has 75 confirmed or suspected
cases of the disease but infectious
disease epidemiologist Brian labus tells
me the risk of transmission is still low
it's typically direct skin to skin
contact usually sexual contact so it's
not the kind of thing we worry about in
a classroom setting but if you believe
you've been in contact and notice a
fever or rash labus says it's important
to get checked out Panic or keep living
your life and I think you know we rather
just keep living our life and though the
alert was startling at first families
here say they'll navigate this all the
best they can to keep Kids Safe
CCSD is working with the health district
to contact Trace here and notify any
parents whose kids need to be monitored
or tested for more information on monkey
pox here in southern Nevada we have a
link on our website 8newsnow.com